uh the gentleman who said you inspired
me in the talk just now thanks to the
inspiration I took some action today
talked to my son this morning called him
I was sorry for being a dick that's
humongous the biggest thing straight
away that me the world how do you you
know it was a really emotional thing for
me that's a big deal that's why I speak
for a living like that little moment but
I looked at Dustin when that happened
and gave him my contact and he made it
know with all the Technologies coming
I'm not going to have to look at Dustin
we're going to upload that video it's
going to understand rhythms and patterns
from AI of things that have worked for
me and me and Dustin in our gut are no
longer going to do post- production the
AI is going to figure it out and put it
out what is that going to mean supply
and demand issues what's going to happen
is it's going to be harder to break
through because everyone's going to be
doing it the fact that everyone here now
can buy a SAS product and make more
content than I make for a fraction of
that will mean that we will have more
supply of content than we've ever seen
before I'm not going to put my head in
the sand we're going to use generative
AI as well and so you're going to have
to be better attention is the number one
asset